[Music]
welcome back to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul and this video we're
breaking down the second episode of
hawkeye on disney plus if you haven't
seen our first breakdown then make sure
you go and check it out right now as we
pointed out all the easter eggs and ties
to the comics and it'll bring you fully
up to speed before we dive into this one
now we pick up immediately after the end
of episode 1 with kate and clint meeting
for the first time this highly
differentiates from the comics as in
those she was introduced in young
avengers 1 back in april 2005. hawkeye
was dead at the time after being killed
in avengers disassembled and she ended
up taking over the mantle they journeyed
to kate's home above herman's hearty
slice and clint asks where she learned
to fight like that kate says she started
martial arts when she was five which was
of course further spurred on by the
death of her father in the opening of
episode one as they indicates place
they're greeted by pizza dog who is
based on lucky from the comics in the
apartment we can catch a target against
kate's back wall and this is somewhat
reminiscent of the trophy that she had
in the first episode which shared a
similar colour scheme the idea of a
target placed around someone's home was
also somewhat mirrored in age of ultron
when tony ended clint spawn and we could
see one hidden away this target later
popped up at the start of avengers end
game when clint and his daughter were
doing target practice and kate being
somewhat of a surrogate daughter is
nicely carried across in this kay gets
changed and comes down wearing purple
which is her signature color from the
comics however it's also clint's 2 and
we know from the trailers that they're
going to be donning similar purple
outfits at some point clint name drops
attracts to mafia because well he knows
who they are and as we learned in
episode 1 they had many run-ins with him
as the ronin in the comics the tracksuit
mafia owned an apartment block that
clint lived in and after they tried to
extort the tenants he took over
throughout the graphic novel he had
several run-ins with them and we already
know from the trailers that they're
gonna appear throughout the series clint
donning their own and mantle sort of
makes sense as hawkeye was of course a
well-known figure but in operating as
the ronin he managed to carry out the
crimes unbeknownst to the world however
the avengers namely nap did know about
what was happening and we also learned
at the end of black without that val had
a photograph of him unmasked just as
kate reassures clint that the tracksuit
mafia don't know who she is they arrive
throwing molotov cocktails and i love
how clint catches one and then throws it
back against the wall of the apartment
we can also catch a poster that says
conquers the crime which is something
that's associated with fencing
foreshadowing the fight later on and yes
i definitely pronounced it wrong now
kate tries to be clever and put the fire
up by shooting an arrow at a fire
extinguisher but because of the
pressurized air within it it just flies
around the room and they have to abandon
the suit at the apartment they head down
into the subway on chambers street and
this was actually the first scene that
got posted on the internet where we got
our debut look at kate in the mcu they
head to a supermarket and kaye asks if
they're gonna go to avengers tower to
hide out but clint says tony sold that
now you might remember at the end of
spider-man homecoming that happy was
moving out all the boxes from it to go
upstate and this is because tony decided
to move everything to avengers hq and to
get rid of the building you might also
remember that at the start of loki
episode 5 that we could catch a
variation on the tower which had kang
written on it this was actually an alias
of kang the conqueror who at least in
one timeline had acquired the building
this was before the multiverse was
completely broken open so potentially
this line was dropped here to hint that
he may have purchased it and we know
that kang is going to be a big baddie
that slice throughout a lot of things so
it just makes a ton of sense to pay lip
service to that here now speaking of
avengers buildings when hawkeye and kate
head to the next location we see a list
of names on the apartments and these
include moira brandon in the comics
brannan actually ended up selling her
estate to the west coast avengers who
turned it into their base of operations
when hawkeye and his wife mockingbird
went to visit her they were ambushed and
unfortunately myra died during this just
before she passed away hawkeye made her
an honorary avenger so it's nice that
they at least gave a nod to her here the
other names could all mean something but
with moira being the only person who
gets their full name on it i'm guessing
that she's the only marvel character
here however if there's some other ones
you recognize then make sure you comment
below and let me know would you kindly
also leave a like if you're enjoying the
video and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns on the series every single
week okay talks her way in by saying
she's got a pizza and they head up to
your auntie's apartment who's away in
florida inside the room we can catch a
poster for creature of the dark galaxy
with moira's name on it along with luke
ballard who's actually a digital artist
that does work for marvel so i'm
guessing that he made this poster clint
heads back to the apartment i absolutely
love how he manages to steal a
firefighter uniform and go inside it's
such a slick one shot that shows his spy
training coming back but unfortunately
the costume has been taken at this point
however after spotting a sticker for nyc
larping clint looks online and discovers
someone has taken it larping also showed
up at the start of loki episode 2 and
i'd never heard of it until the mcu so
what the hell is a bro tell me now back
in the apartment clint catches kate on
the phone to her mother who brings up
the black market auction and the
explosion from the last episode there's
kind of some hints to hear being the bad
guy as this auction is never brought up
again and jax doesn't get in any trouble
for attending it so i don't really know
how eleanor would be aware of it unless
she had some doing in it or i'm just
grasping at straws as always now the big
theory going around at the moment is
that eleanor is actually madame mask who
played a massive part in the hawkeye
comic book story mask actually held a
black mark at auction for a tape that
showed clint apparently murdering a
dictator and if they are one in the same
then elena could have been behind the
whole thing she may have also murdered
almond and that would make sense as he
threatened her in episode one kate says
she's multitasking by using frozen pizza
to stop the swelling on her cut and also
getting it ready for peter dog's
breakfast pizza dog is the name that she
gave the dog in the comics even though
he was called arrow and at the moment i
don't know what to refer to him as
hawkeye fixes the cut on her head and i
love how clint has won in the same
position which kind of shows how similar
they are clint returns to his hotel the
peninsula and we see his son cooper
watching a video of kate as the ronin
saving pizza dog in the comics the dog
got hit by a car and clint had to take
him to the vets in the first issue but
here they completely avoided that cooper
is also wearing purple same as hawkeye's
colors and he's about 45 years old i
thought you got snapped thought he got
snapped a liar now speaking of liars
clint lies to his family about what's
going on and this is the first christmas
he would be having with them after the
events of end game so he's pretty much
giving up spending time with his real
daughter to help out his surrogate one
once more we catch the news anchor from
the end of far from home who introduced
jay jonah jameson into the mcu he's
featured in several mcu films and it's
great that they keep bringing him back
to deliver these reports he's dropping
the news about almond being killed the
night before and how it may be connected
to the ronin you can also catch an ad
for rogers the musical playing on the tv
which we of course saw in the last
episode clint also takes his jacket off
at this point and you can see his tattoo
that he got an avengers end game after
his family got snapped i love it mate i
love it as soon as the life is gone
we're out getting tattoos keem on
now before we get into the next part of
the video i just want to apologize from
the bottom of my heart i know there's a
lot of things that have been exposed
about me on the internet recently and
i'd just like to say a big sorry for all
the money i'm about to save you
that's because our friends over at epic
hero shop.com are doing an infinity war
on prices and right now they're running
an entire cyber week sale on their
custom designs that celebrate every
corner of nerd culture i've picked up a
number of shirts from them and i
absolutely love the unique designs
especially this spider-man no way home
one it's super comfy makes your boy look
super buff and also has a sick design
that you won't get anywhere else or else
i'm a liar
wow paul you look super good in those
clothes
thanks now shut up whilst i tell you
something else okay it sounds like
something i need to listen to no way
holmes did you know dem punks have
opened up the entire vault of t-shirts
and are re-releasing a lot of them
including the new rock star's latest
obsession ones too they've also upgraded
the viral loki gate apollo shirt with a
new and improved mark too they've got
some nerdy neckties pet accessories
socks can never have enough socks can
you and engraved gifts for the person
you love three thousand there's massive
discounts of 15 off at epic hero
shop.com right now so get get yourself
over there why haven't you gone are you
crazy bug some great clothes and merch
and live your best life and i've left a
link in the description below so head
over there right now and be your own
hero tell them kevin spoiler sent you
now please do please do or i won't get
paid and the the bank's going to take my
house away so please go over there right
now
i'm begging
anyway on to the next part of the video
now they head into new york and we can
see the disney store which probably
selling iron man toys in there right now
clint brings up his hearing aid and this
actually pulls from the hawkeye run in
which he had to wear one as he slowly
started to go deaf he can't really
pinpoint when he started to lose it but
the guy's been through a lot over the
avengers films and i bet it's annoying
having to constantly listen to everyone
saying he's the worst avenger he didn't
even get a solo movie as sucker anyway
we see some people cosplaying as
superheroes in the street and these
include two captain americas two iron
mans hulk ant-man thor and a woman with
a bow and arrow who kate thinks is him
but it's actually katniss everdeen see
you suck hawkeye you suck okay offers
some advice it says that he needs some
branding and that since the avengers
appeared that people want heroes to wear
their hearts on their sleeves this show
and the graphic novel are very much
deconstructions of what it means to be a
hero and clint brings up that he's not
selling halloween costumes or 20 a show
though i've kind of been ragging on him
i think it's because hawkeye is very
much a hero that isn't marketable and
it's where you see kids dressed up as
him as they always tend to choose
another avenger over him this is very
much the case with the films too and as
we mentioned he's the only one who
hasn't had a solo film even in the first
avengers movie he was very much
sidelined to getting brainwashed for the
majority of it but kate saw firsthand as
a kid that he can be a hero she was very
much inspired by him and if she can be
then surely we can be too sorry for
saying you suck hawkeye you know what
you're not that bad of a guy now wait
what you doing oh he said so he sends
kate packing after giving her his number
and he mocks the idea of tricaro so yeah
you backed him off being much of an
inspiration however we do know from the
clips on the show that they will be
making an appearance and this also pulls
directly from the comics in which he had
a lot of trick arrows too cake goes to
him with his company bishop security and
even though jack's uncle has just been
murdered she still gives him a bit of a
tough time in the comics jax duquesne
was actually a character known as the
swordsman and this somewhat hints
towards the fencing ability that he has
later on in the episode though he
downplays his skills he's clearly adept
at fighting as when challenged he shows
that he's easily able to parry her this
also explains why he was so eager to get
the ronin sword i think he's very much
being used as a red herring for who
killed almond the pair of course had an
argument during the auction so they're
clearly setting him up in the comics
jack's actually trained hawkeye but due
to their similarity in age i kind of
feel like they're not going to be
connected even though it's always all
connected
clint travels to the larping event and
he's pretty much drafted into having to
play along in order to get the costume
back before he enters you can see a sign
which is in purple and gold and these
are both colors that were used
throughout the hawkeye graphic novel
clint ends up doing it and they have a
big slow motion action scene and i kind
of felt this moment was very fetch
questy and fillery we've gone from
reality being warped in one division
terror attacks in falcon in the winter
soldier the multiverse and all time
breaking up in the loki to larping and
hawkeye so it just kind of feels like a
step down clint even says that he fought
thanos and yeah i'm probably being a
scrooge as it's christmas but it feels
very low level kate is asked to go to
the police station and though nothing
happens this episode i'm guessing that
this plot thread will be picked up next
time elsewhere is the fight to the death
between clint and chris and i must admit
the guy making the sword sound effects
did make me chuckle a bit clint starts
to soften up and he allows chris or
other grylls to call him his real name
now don't get too attached to girls as
he's also from the hawkeye comic book in
that he was murdered by the psychopath
cozy who i believe is also with a
tracksuit mafia grillz lived in clint's
apartment and he got the nickname
because he loved barbecues now this
might not end up happening in the show
but they do play up his nickname for a
clear reason at jack's place he hosts
dinner and kate brings up her knowledge
of weapons which has helped her identify
when someone is trying to stab her in
the back this is of course how armand
died which is when elena interrupts
potentially hinting to her being behind
it all the two end of fencing with jax
down playing how good he is in order to
try and win kate's favor elena says that
she wants to bring kate into the fold at
bishop security and though things settle
down when jax offers her a butterscotch
candy her spoiler sense flares up these
were of course in almonds house and as
he was killed by a sword it all points
towards jax become a mate too obvious
i'm not falling for this [ __ ] when
mephisto is still out there now clint is
ambushed by the tracksuit mafia and this
calls back to the comic books in which
they showed up to the apartment block
and beat him with baseball bats they
captured him and put a bag over his head
and it plays out really similar to what
we see in the show the leader says that
she wants him alive which could be a nod
to echo who we meet at the end of the
episode or it could indeed still be
eleanor but probably echo now echo is
getting her own show down the line so
it's going to be interesting to see how
they bring this character into the
series k tracks clint using her bishop
security app and it triangulates his
location and puts a target on it which
is of course iconography that often
shows up in hawkeye she rings him and i
believe cause he answers as he's not
rushing like the rest of the mafia cause
he used to taunt cake quite a lot so
it's nice that they kind of brought this
over into the series causey is the only
one other than ekko who doesn't wear a
costume
and in the comics the mafia did hire him
to work alongside them now it turns out
the mavia know that kate was in the
costume and this puts clinton a dilemma
as it was actually him who destroyed
their operations kate drops in to save
the day but it doesn't go too well she's
donning her purple costume that's in
line with the comics but realizing that
she's brought a bow and arrow to a
gunfight they're easily captured so at
this point we're introduced to echo
who's listening to a banger absolute
banger ekko is actually a deaf character
and this is why we see her moving her
hands over a speaker system and being
spoken to in sign language in the comics
ekko has photographic reflexes and this
gives her abilities similar to
taskmaster honestly i wasn't a big fan
of what they did with the character of
taskmaster and the black widow movie and
though i don't mind gender swaps they
pretty much stripped the character of a
personality and made her a complete
robot i actually said that i would have
loved to have seen ekko as a widow and
i'm surprised that they didn't use her
for that film as i think that would have
made a lot of sense here we don't really
know what ekko is up to but in the
comics she can copy people completely no
matter their skills that means she can
become an expert ballerina or even a
master guitar player just by watching
someone it's the same when it comes to
her fists too and i believe that she's
going to pick up some archery abilities
from hawkeye and kate throughout the
entire season now this is likely why she
wanted clint alive and we know from the
disney plus day preview that the pair
are going to escape and be chased by the
mafia and echo i really hope things pick
up as these two episodes were kind of
fillery in my opinion i think they could
have pretty much fit the plot points
from both entries into one 60-minute
episode and we could have cut things out
like the larping and all the fencing
stuff maybe clint will end up getting
the larpers to become his allies and
he'll give them real swords but knowing
what we know at the moment it just
seemed like a bit of a waste of time
plot-wise now the series isn't terrible
and there are some good bits in it from
time to time but i kind of wish there
was more urgency to it as it does
meander at some points it's gonna be
interesting to see what happens down the
line and with next week's episode being
the halfway point hopefully we get more
engaging storylines involving echo
causey and potentially the kingpin or
madame mask and obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts on the show so make
sure you comment below and let me know
we're any competition right now and
giving away three copies of the zack
snyder dc trilogy on the 30th of
november and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the first episode which
will be linked on screen right now if
you've seen that then go check out our
one for spiderman no way home which will
also be linked on screen and i love you
three thousand if not then thanks for
sitting through this video i don't love
you anymore but hopefully i'll see you
on the next one and you take care
yourself i've been paul you've been the
best peace